you were clutching their full clutch I
don't like it it's more like looks like
we're over the water like it just died
yeah I've tried before everyday but not
over water time for another adventure
today I'm in Santa Monica by the beach
and I never come here I don't know
anything about this place I live on the
east side of town it's a whole thing
but today I'm using Google search to
find a cool place to eat a cool place to
drink and something new to do all of
them on my life where I already am but
first I gotta find something to do it
with you know make friends right he gets
it hi how are you my friend say it's
gonna be easy
how's it going how's it going hi
they got lanyards good morning good
thanks
oh you asked me how I was doing didn't
stop to hear an answer but he did ask I
was do it whoo there's all these people
working out but there I'll be honest I
don't want a sweaty guest good morning
how are you doing good I have a question
for you do you do you live around here
oh great so you don't know much about
Santa Monica no perfect me neither
that's great that's great there's a
follow-up question if you have nothing
else to do today do you want to hang out
with me today and explore Santa Monica
with my big ol crew of people over there
Oh see all those people yeah yeah it's
her a video obviously that's not just
like a weird like strange on the street
where are you hungry always any kind of
food you would want to have mojitos is
there's been okay things that's women
ocean is seafood too good
yeah I was saying seafood I kind of try
I led you there but that's because I
want seafood I was being so you were
baiting me but you can pick yeah oh nice
for a long day so here's what I'm gonna
do I'm gonna type in a seafood nearby
there's one called the lobster ah great
okay let's go there okay good to know
each I'm Keith Bob Taylor nice to meet
you Taylor great let's go Taylor all
right
okay so what I want to do is also like
have us eat things we've never eaten
before you know never even here before
but also like what have we not had
before anything that's shouting out to
you that you like golden caviar is that
a real thing yeah I've never had caviar
color either why do we get to keep the
jar yes could you tell us how deep how
to do it yes I would get a piece of this
toast huh and then layer up any
accoutrement you like get the caviar on
top sorry this yours oh wow living the
dream oh good I mean I didn't because
because I don't know I want to spend
this kind of money but it's so good so
what who are you what do you do what's
your life I am from Texas oh I'm really
close to being here for three years
yeah I'm from Tennessee and I've been
here for a little over three years Wow
okay looks like we're the same person
no no recently what with the cows name
you got real fresh with that cow and you
didn't know its name counted and seemed
to want to talk this is an engagement
ring yeah it's very nice when did you
get engaged ah one month ago yesterday
I'm engaged too yeah when I proposed I
still hadn't put on pants yet see what's
what's the best thing to do let's just
do things to do in Santa Monica Santa
Monica Pier oh this yeah the Santa
Monica Pier that's probably the main
thing to do rumor has it it's where
route 66
ends really and then what are we gonna
do what else we're gonna do
drink Caprica nutrition where's the
place to see a Sun time I mean this is a
good view but we're already here we've
already done this um rooftop oh yeah
rooftop Bars we're in LA if we do
rooftop Onex rooftop bar okay maybe
we'll do more what doing the morning
[Music]
there at the pier look at this it's
beautiful you're totally right great
work congratulations
well you kind of did like to rub it in
foolish people out now water it must be
freezing so do you like Ferris wheels
there's other safe they feel totally
unsafe this is like we're just slowly
teetering ready to plummet to our deaths
yeah I'm pretty sure
statistically way more people died on
roller coasters and Ferris wheels you
don't know that but it's nights I like
the view is pretty I just wish we were
in like a thing with windows and
seatbelts you know it's been so hot it's
a long day I just want to unwind on a
rooftop how are you I'm here to help you
my name is Louise we're known for the
teeny teeny we made a drink after owner
yeah her name is Tammy Tammy that sounds
really good with basil in it you know I
think I might lean towards the word
eight absolutely you'll love it okay
perfect Thank You Louise I don't know
who's Lucy Lewis but I I was polled did
you say the least
that's right with ya I just went for it
what's your end goal what do you want
most out of life you know here we are on
top of the world looking out over the
whole world what do you what do you want
I want to be happy Lori I want to be a
leave miss Akana
and I want to have an awesome marriage
and
family how many children I do two girls
her name is gonna be juniper of course
why not name children of the berries
thank you it's beautiful
oh my dream looks far more feminine no -
hopefully you get all you moved out here
for Cheers
how's the lady today it's delicious
drink me definitely oh yeah of course
look at that basil leaf so when you do
up to this how do we end such a perfect
day spending all this time out in nature
out and enjoying the real world go and
enjoy the fake world of movies yeah any
movie Lizzie fantastic beef oh I hear
it's crazy visual fantastic beasts show
times maybe we'll check out the 7 p.m.
at the ArcLight and don't have ourselves
a time day we've had
well that's gone goes the birds fly free
yeah thanks for a really solid munch a
pretty good well that's it we did it
thanks to Google search on a new place
to eat a new place to drink something
new to do what what a day huh one day
great a fantastic day and now we're
gonna go see fantastic base yes and
where to find them and find all of them
it's kinda great beam kick up you can't
film movies it's illegal you know that
you can't oh just imagine we're having a
great time when we'll be having a great
time you guys do if you stay over there
all right we're having a lot of people
working out not a lot of people want any
friends